[Music]
you know it is refreshing now to finally
be in the homestretch of this election
doesn't it feel like this election has
been going on for about nine years we're
now we're in the homestretch and the
candidates are pulling out all the stops
this is the latest Mitt Romney released
another ad that features Hispanic voters
speaking in Spanish have you seen it
yeah
yeah the ad ends with him saying I'm
Mitt Romney and I have no idea what
these people are saying you know the
trace the candidate treats trying to
scare people this weekend Mitt Romney
suggested that President Obama wants to
remove the phrase in god we trust' from
US coins yeah or as Romney calls coins
those jingling things you people have he
he thinks they're candy President Obama
spent the weekend campaigning in Florida
he's trying to woo senior citizens wants
to get senior citizens behind him yeah
which may be why Obama starts his
speeches in Florida with hi I'm
President Eisenhower with a tan
yesterday in Florida President Obama
visited a pizzeria did you see this
footage where the owner gave the
president a bear hug and lifted him off
his feet yeah yeah everybody shared a
good laugh and then the Secret Service
shot the man in the face if you saw 16
minutes last night one of the Navy SEALs
was speaking who was involved in the bin
Laden raid and he said the first thing
he did when he got home was go to Taco
Bell yeah yeah so partly bin Laden
wasn't the only one that night who his
pants you saw the movie then he see us
CD movies this weekend huh all right
then too late the number one the number
one movie at the box office again this
weekend was the possession which is a
Jewish version of The Exorcist
yeah the climax of the film is when they
force the ghost to retire to Boca Raton
and it goes willingly yeah alright
alright but I'm not happy Briana's in
the news Rihanna has decided to honor
her late grandmother by getting a giant
tattoo under her breasts in fairness the
grandmothers obituary notice did say in
lieu of flowers please get boob ink it's
been reported that Kim Kardashian's mom
Kris Jenner said that honey Boo Boo's
mom is exploiting her daughter
moments later Kris Jenner was
hospitalized for acute irony poisoning
speaking of Kim Kardashian you all know
that she's now dating Kanye West right
stating Kanye West well it's been
reported this just came out that Kanye
West used to have sex with other women
while watching Kim Kardashian's sex tape
yeah sounds like someone has a great
story to tell their grandchildren
[Music]
want to hear how I met your grandmother
I was doing it with this lady we put in
a tape that's how my story goes I know
if you saw the President's speech last
Thursday at the Democratic National
Convention a lot of people had different
opinions about it but it was pretty
clear to a lot of pundits that the
president was trying to shift the blame
for America's problems and I have to say
I've been thinking about the speech and
looking at it I'm not sure it worked out
so well take a look you see the election
four years ago wasn't about me it was
about you my fellow citizens
you were the change you're the reason
millions of innocent Americans lost
their jobs their homes their life
savings you did that you're dismissed
our problem you're the reason there's a
little girl with a heart disorder in
Phoenix who has no home thank you very I
feel horrible now